[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm a ktla newsman all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
this just in terrible trouble in
afghanistan
[Music]
no i'm not even sure
i've never heard of these teams before
we're not even sure where these teams
are from we just know these kooky
mascots but here we go this first one
very strange it's the salesman trying to
make a flight that's an actual yeah it's
the salesman
trying to make a flight he's going to
try and slam dunk
this is a mascot that should never slam
dunk not really suited to it at all but
let's watch him try the salesman trying
to make a flight go salesman go
[Applause]
hurry
your flight hurry go
you're gonna miss your flight
and missed his fight uh here's an
absolutely terrible mascot should never
dunk it's the funeral urn let's watch
the future
[Applause]
oh i'm sorry everybody i told you uh
okay funeral learn
go
[Music]
there's remains all over here
that's there's nine ways that that's
wrong uh
okay you've probably we've all seen
hipsters whether you're in some cool
part of new york you're in some cool
part of downtown l.a right well here's
the hipster wearing too many fedoras the
hipster wearing too many fedoras
all right hamster go hipster go
don't
[Applause]
oh
that was close
now he's the hipster covered in ash
this one just sounds sad the one-legged
moose let's hear it for the one-legged
moose
[Applause]
let's do one legged moose
[Applause]
yeah the one look at moose is going to
alley you because that's the only way
the one-legged moose can do it go
one-legged moose go
[Applause]
why like the window
yeah that was just awful
[Applause]
someone's got
keep going one legged keep going
the long hop back long long hop back
to that hall of shame over there
[Laughter]
the uh okay this is a terrible idea uh
for it for a mascot should never dunk
the blackjack dealer
[Applause]
i think
this is gonna be a mess but it's the
blackjack dealer alright blackjack
dealer your odds are good let's try
let's go for it go
[Applause]
nicely done
[Applause]
[Music]
this is just a complete mess over here
under the basket
ladies and gentlemen
this last mascot may be the most
impressive all right still a mascot that
should never dunk but ladies and
gentlemen this mascot's very popular
with moms it's the baby cannon
hold it
on your mark get set go
[Applause]
i like you think we can do better who
thinks we can do
better making some adjustments saw it
justin bernadette the second baby is
ready to go and annie do it
i think america can do better
hey
just a little bit more that was online
all right all right it's time we showed
china that we're not gonna lose anymore
coming at you china here we
we're out of babies
does anyone have a baby we could borrow
someone raise their hand
what kind of mother are you
try mine
it's for the country
i do want to promise you that this
worked beautifully in rehearsal let's
take a rare look at america triumphing
in rehearsal
[Applause]
[Music]
can't they give us more of those well
just grab one and stick it in there oh
that's what she said
oh come on
i could do this all day sorry josh
brolin go
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
we'll take a break when we come back
i've never been prouder of this country